what is the tipping point will there be
a war
sad about will their reward there is war
right now we are in war it's just a
different kind of work like for example
you ever been to a family gathering
where there's a lot of politics involved
but if you didn't know about it you
would never know there's work going on i
don't know if you know what i'm talking
about
let's just say you've gone to a family
gathering yeah when you bring your
partner they think everything's good on
the surface but you know what's going on
in the background well i'm even talking
dirtier than that i'm talking about you
go to a family gathering
and you know your mom and your dad's
sister
hate each other like you've seen the
fight nobody else has seen it they just
called each other
you know the worst word just a week ago
but at a family gathering like hey how
are you so how's your kids by the way i
just want you to know my son just
graduated from usc
oh congratulations to your son what
she's trying to say is hey you idiot
my son is better than your son i'm a
better parent than you and the uh
auntie responds and says oh guess what
what our son just bought his own first
house we're so proud of him that he's so
independent that they
doesn't lean on his mommy and daddy for
everything we like that we have so much
respect for our son
and you're just kind of standing there
you say mom and auntie are going at it
right there's a lot of war going on
but if you don't know the inner detail
stories of what's going on you wouldn't
know about it okay so where am i going
with this
so right now we have so many proxy wars
it's not even funny
it's proxy war galore today is what we
have
uh we have so many cyber wars right now
it's not funny
not even funny china to microsoft
russia threatening twitter that's cyber
they're going and they're attacking
them that way very easy we have bio
warfare wars that could happen at any
given time the wars of today are not
going to be the kind of wars that we had
in world war ii or world war one
it's going to be the kind of war that
you can't figure out who attacked you
you know you know how you fight a person
and
you're standing up and you're like hey
you want to go and he punches you in the
face
you know who hits you this is the kind
of fight
where you get hit in the back of the
head you don't know who hit you you get
stabbed you don't know who stabbed you
you're all of a sudden sick you don't
know how you got sick
it's a very dirty word today because
nobody can that the fingerprints aren't
anywhere like imagine somebody robs your
house you call the cops they come what
do they do
well let me see this here fingerprints
put it in their thumb
okay it's a guy named john doe who lives
on 42nd and broadway let's go to his
house right now they pull up
oh he's running from the back get him
hey
finger this is your shoes yes you're rob
you're going to jail you have all the
laptops you stole no i sold it to the
pawn shop well then you're doing jail
time for one year
there's no fingerprints today no
fingerprints today
so it's a it's a very very weird time
today it's
like trump was a president right and
he would have been a phenomenal
president
in the 50s the 60s
because he wouldn't have a way to
constantly share his thoughts on twitter
24 7.
but he would have still been a strong
president on tv but today
he created way too many new enemies we
didn't need
he kept giving birth to new enemies i
don't know if that makes sense or not he
was
constantly pissing off old enemies and
waking them up
i get that like it's it's very much we
admire look at him he's not afraid of
anybody it's great but it's like
i totally get it i understand i admire
too i love the fact that somebody says
no i'm standing up yes stand up
but but don't give birth to new enemies
somebody today has to be a diplomat you
know
that turns enemies into allies into
friends
somebody has to be a synergist today
that just kind of calms the nerves and
it's not biden
okay it's not abiding it's not an obama
it's not a trump
it's it's not it's got to be a different
kind of a personality
but uh you know it's it's a very very
random weird time today somebody has to
be the combination of strength
poise yet at the same time their
ambitions
is to unite and create a
environment where there is confidence
and diplomacy
versus their ambition being i have to be
the most powerful man in the world that
this is this
that's a wrong kind of a time to be a
leader
anyways i mean probably i'm not even
making any sense to the viewer i don't
even know if i'm making sense to you
right now but all i'm trying to say
today
is it's a lot of wars going on that we
cannot see publicly
you can't spot the fingerprints and
it's a time that gives birth to a lot of
extreme personalities and unfortunately
that's the last thing we need today it's
the last thing we need today